En realidad me considero un narrador de historias.
Pero, no las narro como usualmente se hace,
en el sentido de que casi nunca cuento mis propias historias.
En lugar de eso, me interesa construir herramientas que le permitan
a un gran número de personas contar sus historias
a la gente de todo el mundo.
Hago esto porque creo que la gente tiene mucho en común.
Pienso que la gente es muy similar,
pero también pienso que nos cuesta trabajo verlo.
Y, cuando echo un vistazo al mundo veo muchos huecos,
y creo que todos vemos muchos huecos.
Y ellos nos definen.
Hay huecos en el lenguaje,
hay huecos en el origen étnico y racial, existen en la edad,
en materia de género y de sexualidad,
existen en la riqueza y en el dinero, existen en la educación,
y también existen en materia religiosa.
Y, tenemos todos estos huecos y creo que nos gustan estos huecos
porque nos hacen sentir que nos identificamos con algo,
con una pequeña comunidad.
Pero creo que en realidad, a pesar de nuestros huecos,
tenemos mucho en común.
Y pienso que una cosa que tenemos en común es una profunda necesidad
de expresarnos.
Pienso que es un deseo humano muy antiguo. No es nada nuevo.
Pero el asunto de la expresión personal
es que por tradición ha existido un desequilibrio
entre el deseo que tenemos para expresarnos
y el número de amigos compasivos
que están dispuestos a estar con nosotros y escucharnos.
(Risas)
Esto tampoco es nada nuevo.
Desde los albores de la historia humana, hemos intentado rectificar este desequilibrio
creando arte, escribiendo poemas, cantando canciones,
escribiendo guiones editoriales y enviándolos a algún periódico,
chismeando con amigos. Esto no es nada nuevo.
Lo que es nuevo es que en los últimos años
muchas de estas tradicionales actividades físicas humanas,
estos actos de expresión personal, han comenzado a trasladarse al Internet.
Y a medida de que sucedió, la gente ha dejado huellas,
huellas que narran historias de sus momentos de expresión personal.
Y así, lo que hago es escribir programas computerizados
que estudian grandes colecciones de dichas huellas,
y después intentan extraer conclusiones acerca de la gente que las dejó --
lo que sienten, lo que pinsan,
lo que diferencia al mundo de hoy del habitual.
Este tipo de preguntas.
Un proyecto que explora estas ideas,
que se hizo más o menos hace un año,
es una pieza titulada We Feel Fine (Nos Sentimos Bien).
Es una pieza que cada dos o tres minutos escanea
las últimas entradas de blog publicadas en el mundo
buscando frases que comienzan por "Siento" o "Estoy sientiendo."
Y cuando encuentra una de esas frases,
captura la oración hasta el punto,
y después automáticamente deduce la edad, el género,
y la ubicación geográfica de la persona que escribió dicha oración.
Después, al saber la ubicación geográfica y el tiempo,
podemos deducir el tiempo climático
que había cuando la persona escribió la oración.
Toda esta información se guarda en una base de datos
que recaba alrededor de 20.000 sentimientos al día.
Ha estado funcionando por cerca de un año y medio.
Hasta ahora ha recabado cerca de 7 millones y medio de sentimientos humanos,
y les permitiré echar un vistazo
a cómo se visualiza esta información. Así que esto es We Feel Fine.
Lo que ven aquí es una gran masa infestada de partículas,
cada una de ellas representa un sentimiento individual humano
expresado en las últimas horas.
El color de cada partícula corresponde al tipo de sentimiento que hay dentro --
los sentimientos positivos y felices son de color brillante.
Y los sentimientos negativos y tristes son más oscuros.
El diámetro de cada punto
representa la longitud de la oración que hay dentro,
así los puntos grandes contienen oraciones largas,
y los puntos pequeños oraciones pequeñas.
Se puede hacer clic en cualquier punto y expandirlo. Y aquí podemos ver,
"Me sentiría mucho mejor si
pudiera estar en sus brazos en este momento y poder sentir su afecto por mí
en el abrazo de su cuerpo y la ternura de sus labios."
Así que algunas veces se pone bastante sensual
en el mundo de las emociones humanas.
Y todas estas las expresa la gente:
"Objetivamente sé que en realidad no significa mucho,
pero después de pasar tantos años como un pececito en una gran pecera,
es bonito sentirse grande de nuevo."
Los puntos muestran cualidades humanas. Como si tuvieran su propia física,
y se mueven estrepitosamente, como explorando el mundo de la vida.
Y también muestran curiosidad.
Ahora pueden ver algunos de ellos moviéndose alrededor del cursor.
Pueden ver otros
en la esquina inferior izquierda de la pantalla,
cerca de seis palabras. Estas seis palabras representan los seis movimientos
de We Feel Fine. En este momento estamos viendo Locura.
También existe Murmullo, Montaje, Multitud, Métricas y Montículos.
Y ahora les explicaré algunos de ellos.
Murmullos hace que todos los sentimientos vuelen hacia el techo.
Y después, uno por uno, en orden cronológico inverso,
se excusan unos a los otros, ingresando a la lista de desplazamiento de la pantalla de los sentimientos.
"Ya me siento un poquito mejor."
(Risas)
"Me siento confundido e inseguro acerca de qué diablos quiero hacer."
"Aquí me siento excluido de algo maravilloso."
"Me siento muy libre; me siento muy bien."
"Siento que estoy en una neblina de depresión de la cual no me puedo salir."
Y puede hacer clic en cualquiera de estas oraciones para visitar el blog
del cual se recabaron las oraciones. Y de esta forma,
puede conectarse con los autores de dichas frases,
si siente algún grado de empatía.
El siguiente movimiento se titula Montaje.
Montaje hace que todos los sentimientos que contengan fotografías
se extraigan y se muestren en una cuadrícula.
Después, esta cuadrícula representa la fotografía de los sentimientos en el mundo
en las últimas horas.
Se puede hacer clic en cada uno de estos, y se pueden hacer explotar.
Podemos ver, "Simplemente siento que no me voy a divertir
si no estamos los dos." Eso fue de alguien en Michigan.
"Siento como si hubiera estado todo el día frente a una computadora."
(Risas)
Se construyen de manera automática utilizando los objetos encontrados:
"Creo que me siento un poco lleno."
El siguiente movimiento se tituta Multitudes.
Multitudes ofrece diferentes extractos estadísticos
de la población de los sentimientos en el mundo en las últimas horas.
Podemos ver que ahora "mejor" es el sentimiento más frecuente,
seguido por bueno, malo, culpable, triste, enfermo, etcétera.
También tenemos un desglose por género.
Y vemos que en las últimas horas las mujeres son ligeramente
más prolíficas cuando hablan de sus emociones.
Podemos obtener un desglose por edad, que nos da un histograma
de la distribución emocional del mundo.
Vemos que la gente de 20 a 30 años es más prolífica,
seguida por los adolescentes, y después por las personas entre 30 y 40,
y a partir de ahí desaparece rápidamente.
En el clima, los sentimientos asumen las características físicas
del clima que representan,
de manera que aquéllos recabados en un día soleado
giran alrededor como si fueran parte del sol.
Aquellos nublados flotan a manera de brisa.
Los lluviosos caen como si fueran parte de una tormenta,
y los que son como la nieve ondean hacia el piso.
Por último, la ubicación hace que los sentimientos se muevan a sus posiciones
en un mapa global que muestra la distribución geográfica de los sentimientos.
Las métricas ofrecen visualizaciones más numéricas.
Podemos ver que ahora el mundo se siente usado
3.3 veces más que el nivel normal.
(Risas)
Se sienten cariñosos 2.9 veces que el nivel normal, etc.
También están disponibles otras visualizaciones.
Aquí se ven el género, la edad, el clima, la ubicación.
El movimiento final se titula Montículos.
Es un poco diferente a los demás.
Montículos visualiza toda la información como grandes gotas gelatinosas
que se mueven un poco.
Y si dejo apretado el cursor, hacen un pequeño baile.
Podemos ver que "mejor" es el sentimiento más frecuente, seguido por "malo."
Y si después voy aquí, la lista comienza a bajar,
y en realidad se pueden ver miles de sentimientos que han sido recabados.
Pueden ver que el pequeño cursor rosa se mueve,
representando nuestra posición.
Aquí vemos a gente que se siente "aislada," "nauseabunda," " responsable."
También se puede buscar,
si estás interesado en encontrar algo acerca de alguna población.
Por ejemplo, podría encontrar mujeres que se sienten "adictas"
en edad de veinte años mientras está nublado en Bangladesh.
(Risas)
Pero eso se los voy a evitar.
Aquí les mostraré algunos de mis montajes favoritos que han sido recabados:
"Siento tanto de mi padre vivo en mí que ni siquiera hay espacio para mí misma."
"Me siento muy sola."
"Necesito estar en algún pueblo de un sureño de clase baja
para poder sentirme hermosa."
"Me siento invisible para tí."
"No lo escondería si la sociedad no me hiciera sentir como si lo tuviera que hacer."
"Me siento enamorada de Carolyn." "Me siento tan atrevida."
"Siento que estos bichos raros en realidad son un bien para la vida universitaria."
(Risas)
"Me encanta cómo me siento hoy."
Y bueno, como pueden ver We Feel Fine utiliza una técnica
que yo llamo "observación pasiva."
Lo que quiero decir es que observa a la gente de manera pasiva
a medida que viven sus vidas. Escanea los blogs del mundo
y observa lo que la gente está escribiendo,
y esta gente no sabe que está siendo observada o entrevistada.
Y por esto,
uno termina obteniendo respuestas muy sinceras, francas y honestas
que a menudo son muy conmovedoras.
Y esta es una técnica que por lo general prefiero en mi trabajo
porque la gente no sabe que está siendo entrevistada.
Simplemente están viviendo la vida --y terminan actuando así.
Otra técnica está cuestionando de manera directa a la gente.
Y esta es una técnica que exploro en un proyecto diferente,
el Yahoo! Time Capsule, (la Cápsula del Tiempo de Yahoo!)
la cual fue diseñada para tomar huellas digitales del mundo en 2006.
Se dividió en diez temas muy simples:
amor, rabia, tristeza, etc --
cada uno de ellos contenía una pregunta abierta muy sencilla
que se le hacía al mundo: ¿Qué ama? ¿Qué lo hace enojar?
¿Qué lo entristece? ¿En qué cree?, etc.
La cápsula del tiempo estuvo disponible en línea durante un mes,
traducida a 10 idiomas, y así es como se veía.
Es un globo que da vueltas,
su superficie está compuesta en su totalidad por imágenes
y palabras y dibujos de la gente
que los envió a la cápsula del tiempo.
Los diez temas se muestran y orbitan la cápsula del tiempo.
Puedes filtrar esta información y ver lo que la gente ha enviado.
Esta es la respuesta a ¿Qué es hermoso? "Miss Mundo."
Existen dos modalidades en la cápsula del tiempo.
Existe One World (Un Mundo), que presenta al globo dando vueltas,
y Many Voices (Muchas Voces), que divide la información en tiras de película
y le permite filtrarlas una por una.
Así que este proyecto fue delimitado por un evento sorprendente
que se llevó a cabo en el desierto de Alburquerque en Nuevo México,
en Jemez Pueblo, en donde por tres noches consecutivas,
los contenidos de la cápsula se proyectaron a los lados
de las paredes del antiguo Cañón Red Rock,
que mide alrededor de 200 pies de altura. Fue realmente increíble.
También proyectamos hacia el espacio los contenidos de
la cápsula del tiempo en código binario con un láser de 35 vatios.
Pueden ver la línea naranja abandonando el piso del desierto
con ángulo de unos 45 grados. Fue sorprendente
porque a la primera noche observé toda esta información
y realmente comencé a ver los huecos de los que hablé antes --
las diferencias en edad, género y riqueza, etc.
Pero, mientras más miraba esto,
y veía estas imágenes a través de las rocas,
me di cuenta de que estaba viendo los mismos arquetipos
descritos una y otra y otra vez.
Ya sabe: bodas, nacimientos, funerales, el primer coche, el primer beso,
el primer camello o caballo --dependiendo de la cultura.
Y fue muy conmovedor. Esta fotografía fue tomada la última noche
desde un acantilado distante, a unas dos millas de distancia,
desde donde los contenidos de la cápsula se transmitían al espacio.
Y hubo algo muy conmovedor
acerca de esta expresión humana de ser proyectado al cielo de la noche.
Y comenzó a hacerme pensar mucho acerca del cielo nocturno,
y cómo los humanos siempre han utilizado el cielo nocturno
para proyectar sus grandes historias.
De niño en Vermont, en la granja donde crecí,
a menudo veía el oscuro cielo
y veía el cinturón de Orión, de tres estrellas, el Cazador.
Y ahora de adulto, me he vuelto más consciente
de los grande mitos griegos que se manifiestan en el cielo cada noche.
Como Orión al enfrentarse al toro enfurecido.
Perseo volando para rescatar a Andrómeda.
Zeus luchando contra Cronos por el Monte Olimpo.
Estas son las grandes historias de los griegos.
Y me hizo preguntarme acerca de nuestro mundo de hoy.
Y me hizo preguntarme específicamente,
si pudiéramos crear nuevas constelaciones hoy en día,
¿cómo se verían?, ¿qué serían?
Si pudiéramos crear nuevas imágenes en el cielo, ¿qué dibujaríamos?
¿Cuáles son las grandes historias de hoy?
Y estas son las preguntas que inspiraron mi nuevo proyecto,
que debuta hoy aquí en TED.
Nadie ha visto esto aún, públicamente.
Se llama Universe (Universo), y rebela nuestra mitología moderna.
Utiliza la metáfora de un cielo de noche interactivo.
Así que, es un placer mostrárselo esta noche.
Así que, Universe se presentará aquí.
Y verán que comienza con un campo de estrellas en movimiento,
con una Aurora Boreal en el fondo,
que se transforma con color. El color de la Aurora Boreal
se puede controlar usando la barra de color en la parte inferior,
y lo pondremos en rojo.
Y así pueden ver esta forma de estrellas en movimiento.
Éstas no son sólo pequeños puntos de luz, pequeños píxeles.
Cada una de estas estrellas representa
un evento específico en el mundo real --
una cita dicha por alguien, una imagen,
un artículo de noticias, una persona, una compañía. Ya sabe,
una especie de personalidad heroica.
Y pueden notar que a medida que el cursor comienza
a tocar algunas de estas estrellas, las formas comienzan a aparecer.
Aquí podemos ver un pequeño hombre caminando, o tal vez una mujer.
Y aquí vemos una fotografía con una cabeza.
Pueden ver cómo empiezan a aparecer las palabras.
Y éstas son las constelaciones;
éstas son las constelaciones de hoy.
Puedo encender todas,
y podrán verlas moviéndose ahora en el cielo.
Este es el universo de 2007, los últimos dos meses.
La información proviene de miles de servicios de noticias
de todo el mundo.
Está utilizando la IPA (Interfaz de programación de aplicaciones) de una gran compañía con la que trabajé
en Nueva York, llamada Daylife.
A este nivel es una visión del espíritu de la época
de la mitología actual del mundo durante los últimos meses.
Así que podemos ver en dónde aparece, como con el Presidente Ford,
Irak, Bush. Y en realidad podemos aislar sólo las palabras --
yo los llamo "secretos" -- y podemos hacer que creen una lista
en orden alfabético. Y vemos cómo Anna Nicole Smith
ha jugado un papel importante recientemente.
El Presidente Ford --este es el funeral de Gerald Ford.
Podemos hacer clic en cualquier cosa en Universo
y hacer que se vuelva el centro del universo,
y todo lo demás ingresará en su orbita.
Así que, haremos clic sobre Ford, y ahora se hará el centro.
Y las cosas relacionadas con Ford ingresarán en su orbita
y girarán a su alrededor.
Podemos aislar únicamente las fotografías, y ahora podemos verlas.
Podemos hacer clic en una de ellas
y hacer que la fotografía sea el centro del universo.
Ahora las cosas relacionadas con ella girarán a su alrededor.
Podemos hacer clic sobre esta y vemos la imagen icónica
de Betty Ford besando el ataúd de su esposo.
En Universo, es como si no hubiera un fin. Es infinito,
y puede hacer clic en cualquier cosa.
Esta es una representación fotográfica titulada Fotografías.
En realidad podemos ser más específicos al definir nuestro universo.
Así que si queremos,
podemos ver el aspecto del universo de Bill Clinton,
y ver qué ha hecho la semana pasada.
Y ahora, tenemos un nuevo universo, limitado sólo a
lo relacionado con Bill Clinton.
Podemos hacer que sus constelaciones aparezcan aquí.
Podemos extraer sus secretos,
y podemos ver que tiene mucho que ver con candidatos,
con Hillary, con lo presidencial y con Barack Obama.
Podemos ver las historias
de las que Bill Clinton está formando parte ahora.
Y se puede acceder a cualquiera de ellas.
Así vemos que Obama y los Clinton se reunieron en Alabama.
Verán que esta es una historia importante;
existen muchas cosas en esta orbita. Si accedemos a ella,
obtendremos diferentes perspectivas de la historia.
Pueden hacer clic en cualquiera de ellas para salir y leer el artículo
en la fuente. Este es de Al Jazeera.
También podemos ver a las superestrellas. Éstas serían la gente
que son como los héroes y heroínas inminentes
en el universo de Bill Clinton. Así que aquí está Bill Clinton, Hillary,
Irak, George Bush, Barack Obama, Scooter Libby --
estas son las personas de Bill Clinton.
También podemos ver un mapa mundial, y nos mostrará el alcance geográfico
de Bill Clinton en la última semana, más o menos.
Vemos que ha estado concentrado en los EE.UU
porque probablemente ha estado en campaña
pero también ha estado activo en Oriente Medio.
Y también podemos ver una línea de tiempo.
Y comprobamos que el sábado estuvo más tranquilo,
pero regresó al trabajo el domingo en la mañana,
y en realidad desde enconces ha ido decayendo.
Y no está únicamente limitado a la gente o a las fechas,
también podemos usar conceptos.
Si escribo cambio climático durante todo 2006,
podremos ver cómo se ve el universo.
Aquí tenemos nuestro campo de estrellas, aquí nuestras formas,
y aquí nuestros secretos.
Y vemos de nuevo que el cambio climático es muy grande.
Nairobi, conferencia global, ambiental.
Y también existen citas que pueden leer,
si están interesados en las citas relacionadas con el cambio climático.
Y bueno, en realidad es algo infinito.
Las superestrellas en el cambio climático del 2006:
Los Estados Unidos, Gran Bretaña, China.
Estos son los países principales que definen este concepto.
Así que esta es una pieza que requiere exploración.
Estará en línea en algunos días, probablemente el próximo martes.
Y ustedes podrán utilizarla y explorar
lo que puede ser su propia mitología personal.
Notará que en Daylife --más bien en Universo,
se sostiene tanto la noción de una mitología global,
representada por algo tan amplio como por ejemplo el 2007,
como una mitología personal.
A medida que buscan lo que es importante para ustedes en su mundo,
verán el aspecto de sus constelaciones.
Así que ha sido un placer. Muchísimas gracias.Gracias
(Aplausos)